about walking onto a beach i'm talking
about walking into a party i'm talking
about
demanding uh the things that other
people are getting
you can demand them you don't get them
always right but you're allowed to
demand
right so you can like if you're not
getting stuff like
show up with a bunch of your friends in
black to serve
your suburban area and bang on those
doors and get that [ __ ] green new
deal that's what you're saying yeah but
you might get shot in the face
yeah in fact you will but you might you
should you might be able to nominate
aoc for the next presidential promise
she's not she's not
i just want to know if you're
encouraging looting right now no but i
don't get what you want guys i
understand that it's fun
i understand it is very fun it's very
very fun people would not be doing it if
it wasn't for if they burned down
to joe's it's fun they're 20 21 22 year
old kids it's like that's what we would
do we're trying to meet women this is a
joke
when i was 19 i used to go around with a
slingshot my boy had a slingshot we
would go and we would break bus
terminal windows on francis lewis
boulevard and we would just [ __ ]
shatter bus terminal windows
if i was a lot if i was a 19 year old
kid right now i'd be at the protest
[ __ ] breaking windows of police
precincts when i was 17 i was [ __ ]
lending [ __ ] janitors eight hundred
thousand dollars to buy their dream home
on long island and now they're dead in
the streets so
who cares so we really hope you enjoyed
that episode whatever it was about this
is just a stock thing that we're taping
on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild
[Music]